special day around major league baseball
as derek jeter and larry walker ted
simmons and marvin miller officially
inducted into the hall of fame sandy
alcantara will take the ball tonight
always fun to watch sandy go to work
when he has been locked in this season
and that's been more times than not
sandy stares in into the motion his
first in this ball game a bounce right
back to the mound reaching down to field
it behind him sandy throws onto first
for the nice way to start the night 32
home runs now 84 driven and he slashes
one down the right field line and
that'll go to the corner and pete's got
himself another extra base hit ball
rolls under the fence sanchez
indicating to the umpires pete should
keep running
just in case keep running pete just in
case and now they finally signal ground
rule double
a 2-2 and sandy gets the strikeout in
his 26 starts this year he has not given
up more than four runs so four runs or
less 73 big league wins and his last
start against miami he went five
scoreless
curve ball hit in the air shallow center
in comes pilar out goes baez and he
makes the running catch he is amazing
it's the slider the other way that's a
base hit on the right field
chased down by sanchez baez takes a hard
turn and holds on there sanchez has a
very strong arm
by the pitch or did it hit the back he
got him he got hit okay
1-1 there's the ground ball it's right
to jazz right on the bag and a double
play for alcantara
as de la cruz keeps it fair down the
right field line that should be extra
bases
he is on his way to second and he'll
stop right there
with a one-out double de la cruz gets to
third but there are two outs
and now alex jackson to the dish
now you really have to be disciplined as
a hitter to stay on the fastball and
react to the curve or you will get blown
away
lined and just over the leap of lindor
it's an rbi single for alex jackson
and the marlins take a one-to-nothing
lead
nissan base hit right center field alex
jackson's on his way to third nissan
takes a turn he'll stay put and for esan
diaz it snaps an 0 for 29 slump
02 hill
and takes
a slider for strike three sandy about
throws 37th pitch and on 3-2 that's
outside ball four
runner goes
throw from jackson is right there got
him
tailed a little bit to the second base
side of the bag and it was right into
lenore and jazz caught it and applied
the tag
whoa and uh chisholm for the second time
looks like he almost hurt himself
swinging at the breaking ball from hill
oh my gosh that's the second time his
feet came out from under him in that
at-bat we missed it by a foot it's a
ruthian swing
into right field sanchez racing in
diving and makes the play
what a play by jesus sanchez in right
field to take a hit away from pete
alonso
it's as simple as that change up gets
conforto
but he's got to make contact and he does
not right there
he's not going
this time he strikes him out of the high
fastball and that'll do it for the
bottom of the fourth five strikeouts for
hill
sandy blows away pilar with a hundred
mile an hour fastball
on o2 swinging to miss a fastball at 100
miles per hour he hits triple digits for
the first time in the game a second
consecutive two strike editing for sandy
alcatraz strikes out for the second time
and the curveball strikes out chisholm
side retired seven strikeouts now for
hills
sandy gets the strikeout 99.
on 3-2 landorus swinging a foul tip
jackson hangs on for the strikeout
number eight in the game for sandia
contra
slow roller left side vr's got it strong
throw but a little bit too quick alfaro
beats it out
sanchez chases for strike three so once
he'll throw that up and end curveball
sanchez was overmatched from there
de la cruz gets a curveball and drills
it to center pilar misjudged it but then
comes in and dives to make the catch
pierlar started back
didn't realize that it was knuckling and
then made the adjustment and made the
grab
3-2
is a cold strike three inside corner
michael conforto will now step in he's
been struck out twice
and this one's thrilled to deep right
field back osachi is looking up and it's
out of here
michael conforto ties the game
conforto gotta change up and drills his
12th home run of the year and the mets
get even in the seventh what a big hit
for conforto and the match against
alcantara who had it rolling
baez down on strikes
and another double-digit strikeout
performance for sandy alcatra jerice
familia takes over his 55th game this
season
and line base it for esan diaz this will
test the gap in left center cut off by
mcneil nicely done and that will keep
isan at first base here's the pitch from
familia he gets the bunt down mccann
throws to second it's high
so maybe that's the best case scenario
one to rojas
and he hits one back toward the middle
there's baez to step and fire for the
double play side retired
and polar went around
so make it 11 for sandy
well his career high and strikeouts has
been matched again a dozen strikeouts
for sandy alcantara
jorge alfaro base it up the middle
back-to-back hits for georgie tonight as
he takes a turn around first diaz behind
him those guys have to do the job this
might help left side tough play for
lindor safe at second
at the plate grounded past the mound but
right at the bag is bias for the step
and throw for the second straight inning
bias starts the four four three double
play we're on deck alonzo behind him and
vr lines one in the center field for a
base hit so after chasing two sinkers he
got one in the middle of the plate and
he lines a base hit to start the ninth
inning 2-2
and alonso chases the slider another new
career high for sandy alcantara one ball
two strikes
he struck him out
14 strikeouts for sandy alcatra
02 pitch
is down the right field line a fair ball
into the corner
alex jackson racing to second
and he's in there with a double
[Applause]
three two pitches upstairs ball four
payoff pitch
outside ball four winning run moves to
third and miguel rojas is coming to the
plate oh two coming to rojas
and he struck him out with a curve ball
huge strikeout for seth lugo for the
second out of the night
on the ground up the middle grabbed by
lindor the throw to first in time and we
are going to extra innings
he gives way to anthony bender 51st game
for him so conforto at second baez at
the plate one-two pitch swing and a miss
bender goes to the slider
ground ball up the middle got a piece of
bender he tries to track it down shovel
pass over to first and they got him
anthony bender
what a play
we had to see a flip play of some sort
today right absolutely
sierra gets the bunt down diaz bare
hands throws and baez makes it an
unbelievable play
to really save the game
if that gets by him jazz is scoring
easily so with two outs it's up to brian
de la cruz jazz is the potential winning
run at third
that one's out to center field almora
going back still going back this one is
off the wall and brian de la cruz brings
home the game winning run it's a marlins
walk-off win
that may be as questionable a move as
luis rojas has made all season pitching
to a red-hot brian de la cruz with a
struggling leewand diaz on deck and de
la cruz comes through with the
game-winning hit against edwin diaz to
win it for miami